all right
Lucy Lucy where you from where'd you
grow up um I grew up in Oregon
Eugene tell me about your uh family
growing up you had Mom and Dad um yes I
had a mom and dad um parents got
divorced probably when I was in sixth
grade kind of [__] with me you know um
he was a little
traumatic um me and my twin brother it
was a little hard on us with us like
kind of like getting used to us being
away from you know our dad and our mom
together you
know and it was a little crazy it was
but um it played a big part in where I'm
at today right now so any abuse in your
childhood I'm sorry any abuse in your
childood yeah um my
dad
uh he used
to he slapped me in my face many times
and gave me bloody lips he gave me
bruises um I remember seeing my brother
being thrown down a hallway literally
picked up by my dad and thrown like that
you know um my mom was never present cuz
she was always at work cuz she was
afraid of him so me my brother and my
sister had to take that that pain you
know we had to deal with him coming home
from
work and him just being who he is you
know he would beat us with a back
scratcher
[__] was he drinking anything that he
had no usually sometimes yes he would
drink beer but he he was just angry I
don't know why but he was just an angry
person he didn't like it he didn't love
his
life and he took it out on his children
and
it
hurt
um but because of
that I yell I yell at people because he
yelled at me you know like he he would
yell at me he would yell in my face he
grabbed my shirt one time and he pulled
me close and he scared the [__] out of
me like like that's traumatic you have a
temper yeah and it's short it's I'm a
good person but like because of my
father you know it it was
uh he kind of [__] that up for me so
he was in my life but he wasn't you know
yeah but what kind of girl were you in
high school what kind of girl in high
school what kind of teenager were you I
was bullied I was bullied by my own twin
brother he had a lot of friends and and
he he would force me to to [__] with his
friends like hey go you know go go in
the room with him let him [__] finger
you you know just let him you know and
it made me uncomfortable I didn't like
it and then there was this one point
where I did it just because I didn't
want to hear it anymore my parents W
home
and it [__] with me because after that
he went to the same school as me as well
and he started buling me talking [__]
about you know me down there and
everything so it really got to the point
where my brother started being like
just you know just talking [__] you know
just saying haha you know you you smell
this and that like it's just it's not
fun like being bullied or being saying
that you're going to or somebody's going
to [__] you up or somebody's going to
beat your ass because of what somebody's
spreading around like
rumors it really
[__] hurt me you know so I I was just
a loner in in high school and and in
middle school I didn't even have my own
twin to be by my back or have my back
you know yeah you graduate I didn't no
um I actually got my GD
2021 um
yeah it
was hard but I did it though you know
how old are you now 25 25 and you're
working Figaroa Street yes how long
you've been doing that for about two
months oh you're brand new I'm new here
to La I've never been here I like I I
met someone at the Union
Station and uh kind of show me the ropes
you know I met a few few women as well
they kind of show me you know what did
you did you ever do this kind of work
before no so this is this is new for you
yes how are you liking it so far it's
all right at least I can wear clothes we
like if I'm hot outside I don't got to
like be sweating constantly you know
you're almost overdressed for Figaroa
Street nah I don't think so I was going
to wear a dress honestly I really was
but I think what I'm wearing right now
is is is it's good but I'm new I like I
I don't know I just present myself like
how everybody the guys mainly tell me
they give me advice you know they're
like put your hair and bigy Tails okay I
got you wear some tennis shoes okay I
got you wear some nice you know
something something shows your legs I
got tattoos on the back of my legs
anyway too so you know but it's it's
definitely different but I'm adapting so
are you making money hell yeah yeah hell
yeah I'm making
money you work say the amount what yeah
I know you work with somebody or on your
own both I usually have somebody cuz
like I don't know nobody out here so he
helps me with introducing to people but
then again I take it upon myself to go
out there I like to meet new people so I
do your typical encounter is a is a
usually a Mexican
gentleman I assume um usually yes and
they'll pull up and you guys do a car
date or yes but the Was it crazy and I
don't speak Spanish you don't speak
Spanish I'm more native I'm na like I'm
native I'm Native American I'm not
Mexican oh is that right yeah so I'm
Nao and a lot of people they come up to
me they're like and I'm like uh I don't
know what the [__] to
say and I'm feel stupid but um when I
first came out here I actually had a guy
that I was with
and he was evil he was
mean he left bruises he left marxy be my
ass um but I've had Trauma from my
childhood from leading up you know um
I've had many many many many people
just I don't know it's it's just a lot
like I came out here this was unexpected
you know coming from Oregon down to here
it's a whole another like
it's a whole another
level and it was very intimidating out
here
honestly
but you're adapting exactly I got to do
what I got to do I got to make that
money you
know so are you did you have dreams of
doing something else with your life I
wanted to be a a a lawyer criminal
lawyer I wanted to be in the
courts um
but I had a lot of people that I knew
especially like my own family they were
on the other side of the
law I have a that is a dad that's a s
so you know me being a criminal lawyer I
don't know about that
but
um it changed though like it I wanted to
go to school for cooking for like you
know food
culinary and then I wanted to go to
school for microblading doing the
eyebrows but
now I don't know honestly like it kind
of like there's a lot of [__] that I've
been through in the last two months that
really kind of like [__] with me to
where I don't know I just got to take
every day as a blessing and thank God
that I'm wake up you know does this work
affect you
emotionally
um at first it was but I try not to let
it because what I do I had to make money
for myself for me to live to
survive
and I mean at the end of the day it does
but I don't let that [__] affect me
though do you have kids I don't no kids
no it makes it easier on you
yeah makes it a lot
easier
and do you use drugs to uh help you deal
with what you do I drink a
lot a lot a lot like um every
day I smoke Crystal
myth I snort it
sometimes um
fentanyl I had a really good person in
my life that passed away from that
because he overdosed and I would never
touch that [__] in my life ever
again but crystal meth yes I get high as
[__] off that
[__] but alcohol that's my go-to I love
it I love whiskey I love getting [__]
up off of Jack Daniel it makes what you
do easier yes and it it it relaxes me
you know like cuz I get I have anxiety
from the [__] that I've been through in
my life I get anxiety attacks once I
Take a Shot Two Shots three shots good I
feel so relaxed I'm good I just need
listen to some
music it's a business everything's all
good what do you think of the guys that
are your
customers
um I don't know I don't really I don't
really look I don't really like
interpret it in that way I just do what
I got to do and you know move on with my
day like
there's I don't know if I could say dick
but you know the dick is a dick like
it's it's ordinary you know the
face that's just
whatever is it changing the way you see
men or or relationships no because I
feel like
nowadays there's no loyalty in my
opinion there's no loyalty because in my
past relationship I've always been
cheated on there's always been a better
[__] than me and I'm like there will
always be a better [__]
but me who I am inside [__]
don't see that [__] they don't care they
just see the
outside so that's what I'm doing right
now like they see the outside that's it
you don't need to see the inside I'm not
going to let you in if you don't [__]
deserve
it plain and simple so I detached myself
from that because I've been hurt so many
times I'd rather shut it off and do what
I do with what I
got
then get hurt again cuz I put my heart
into some [__] and [__] me up in the
end so have You' been in love before yes
my baby daddy that passed
away yeah sorry about that
yeah it's okay but you know I've had a
lot of lost loved ones
um
that mean a lot to me I actually lost my
wallet I lost all my [__] credit
cards my debit card my social security
card my ID card I lost my phone I lost
my phone and had all my pictures and
everything in it so I don't got [__]
right now and it sucks because I had to
lose it in LA and I'm like out of all
place I had to lose it in LA huh but
everything happens for a reason so I'm
going just take it as a blessing you
know oh with what I'm giving you you'll
probably it'll help you get a new
phone yeah that's the goal that's
definitely the go you mentioned you had
a baby daddy does that mean you have a
baby uh miscarriage it was I consider
him as my baby daddy because the baby
was born
but he died shortly after I'm sorry
about that so technically my baby daddy
but yeah what what is your biggest fear
now huh what would you say is your
biggest fear now going insane
losing um the capacity to control my own
mind you know like cuz just trauma plays
a lot especially with a woman and and
the [__] that I'm doing right
now I can lose control especially when
I'm drinking doing
drugs family issues you know it all
[__] with your head if you get deeper
into drugs or
alcohol yeah um there's [__] PCP out
there there's hairo there's [__]
fanal you know I was doing it with my
baby daddy I ain't going to lie but I
stopped because it made me it made me
not she said made me
puke but the thing is is I went through
it with him to try to get out of it with
him to know what he was going through to
feel the
the type of addiction that he had but it
in the end it took his life so I just
stopped cuz it was nasty that [__] stunk
that [__] was gross it made me puke
after I smoked a cigarette i' be
throwing up and
everything so I just stick to what I
know is alcohol and
[__] Sometimes some weat but I smoke
meth
yeah you have any crazy stories of being
out there in two
months
fig Street not always not really yeah
said is it's crazy you got some
unpredictable [__] going on out there
but what hours are you working I work
late late so like I go at 9: and then I
work all the way till 3:00 3: in the
morning yeah and I I do what I got to do
you know but there's just just some
weirdos there weirdos weirdos and if
they're paying high
let's go but if you make me [__] feel
uncomfortable I'm walking the [__] out
you know I have I have I have an
expectation you know
like I can't just do like you know like
I don't know I'm not trying to like talk
no [__] but if it's a bum and he stinks
and he's nasty but he's got
$600 hell no keep that [__] $600 keep
that [__] to yourself go find another
one I need a man that is clean period um
I like a man that's decent not no stank
ass [__] not no dirty ass on his
face and for damn sure like you can't be
dirty down now for sure like you can
that's just my expectation but you know
everybody's different and I get get a
lot I get a lot and that's good though
you have a lovely personality I'm sure
that helps yeah I try not to that's what
I drink I try to like
I shut on or like I put on my ego when I
shut off have you been working all night
last night I worked for probably about 5
6 hours but that was it so you had some
sleep
yeah and I was able to wake up do my
makeup get ready for for this you know
but uh usually I'm out there 10 12 and
you work every
day um the only days I don't work is
Saturday and no Friday and Saturday cuz
those are the days I like to kick back
and drink by myself I got my own spot so
I just I like my own peace you know is
there competition amongst the other
girls out there hell no I'm a bad [__]
I don't give a [__] whether these girls
want to look the way they want to look
I'm my own unique self and I'm authentic
and I keep it real so that's all I'm
that's all I'm facts that's on God I put
that so no but I mean the truth is a guy
rolls up you're right you know you'll be
if you don't want me [__] bye you'll be
right up one guy's alley whereas another
guy wants a short girl or a fat girl or
a exactly tall girl or whatever you know
we all come in shapes different sizes
but and different colors but we are all
women you know we all have the same you
know but it it all plays
within who you are and what you can
do do do you think prostitution should
be
legalized
honestly yes cuz I feel like us women as
being human beings we have a right to do
what we want we can do whatever the [__]
we want just like how men can to make
money especially when we have children
or a family yes guaranteed
facts don't make us
any lower or inferior to a man or to any
other woman that's at that's working at
a PhD level I'm still making money so is
she we're still women we're still trying
to do what we got to do for us and for
our family
period I think I think in some ways you
guys are therapists also for some guys
that just cannot get a woman you're
right then they can go down to figure I
feel like I was a [__] psychologist
with my
ex cuz that [__] was crazy I'm
telling you was a narcissist but I came
out here and I'm you know I met a few
guys but like I noticed that there's a
lot of people that have bipolar
disorders I I met a lot dis huh there's
a lot of disorders out there it's all
mental instability M but it it's up to
you to usually from a bad childhood
create and control your own mind you
know like I suffer from anxiety yes but
I've been through a lot of [__] to
where what doesn't kill me makes me
stronger so I take that and I [__]
grow from it you know I build myself
myself I don't break myself I don't let
myself fall you know farther than I'm
already you know I got [__] like boo
boos like on my heels I was kicking it
at the [__] lax the other day for 7
hours trying to find a [__] plane
again I never did but I took it upon on
myself to do what I got to do and never
give
up and even though I had bruises and
[__] cuts and blers on my feet I
still walked and I did what I had to do
you know and and look at where I am I'm
in my own [__] place right now it
just happened yesterday you had your own
apartment yes and I did what I had to do
you know I I had to do it for
myself you know like I'm going through a
lot of [__] but I feel like I'm Healed
I I love myself everybody's got to love
themselves and I hope everybody loves
themselves you know one day they can
find them find God you
know
L see what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important lesson H let me
think I would say don't let nobody
control you in any way shape or form
that's that's that's all I can that's
all I can come up with that's great all
right Lucy thank you so much all right
thank you good luck out
there